a long requested feature was just  quietly introduced to the destiny  companion app in bungee net the ability  to transfer items to and from your vault  there'll be no more wasting time  switching characters and flying to the  vault every time you forget a weapon  let's imagine a scenario you're in  crotas end with your hunter and realize  you forgot your baller horn on your  warlock instead of sitting through five  different loading screens now the  process is simple step one send the  weapon to the vault from the Warlock  step to grab it as the hunter step three  become legend this doesn't just work  with weapons let's say you finally have  enough glimmer to upgrade your armor  pull the radiant charge from the vault  you're good to go if you forgot heavy  scent it's just a few seconds away many  bungees changes get positive and  negative reactions from the community  but this feature is sure to please any  regular player of destiny  you